[Music]
now you come from a really big family I
got to know I know you have Ava but have
you ever thought of expanding your
family beyond that not at the moment
dealing with the three-year-old is very
challenging and it's a lot but I think
eventually yes you know after Mike and I
tie a knot
don't be more right not right now right
now have there been conversations on
when you guys wouldn't want to do
something like that get engaged oh yeah
have that happen yeah good well good to
know that you guys are in a good place
always love to hear yeah we are yeah
Mike are good what's the secret to
successfully co-parenting a
three-year-old um communication mm-hmm
that's the biggest thing just between us
like you know making sure we're on the
same page and just communication and
organization oh yeah especially with a
girl like organization is key I actually
saw that Angela recently posted
something and I looked at a little
corners it said pastry 2018 are you guys
gonna be partnering up she put that out
there she'd recently put it out there I
thought I thought at the top of one of
her sketches we've been talking about
doing some work together nothing is
official yet but we've definitely been
discussing and you know pastry was our
baby so to be able to revive it would be
awesome but we'll see and how would you
like to see it evolve this second oh um
I would love to just revamp it and have
something I can give to my daughter you
know like it's such a fun company and
the way it started was just and so much
fun so I think we'd concentrate a lot on
children shoes would you let your
daughter and possibly her son give input
oh yeah absolutely
I'll start that royalty Brown starting
cause I was like why not I think Ava can
design some sneakers so I think would be
really heavily focused on like the
children's wear that's awesome I love
that the next phase of mommy's on the
moon yeah that's so awesome makes me
happy to think about so yeah I happen
[Music]
you